so I want to tell you how I came to the
GSB and how it was the next step on a
very well-defined career path but that's
not true I applied to the GSB because I
didn't like what I was doing and I came
to the GSB because I was not passionate
about what I was doing and to be quite
frank even during the first year here at
Stanford at the GSB I was trying to find
something I'm really passionate about
and I know this might not be true for
all of you in this room but some of you
do struggle to find our passion I know
it's true for a couple of my friends and
classmates so instead of freaking out in
how to find your passion I'd ask you to
lean back a few minutes and listen to me
because I found a way how I know how to
find my passion I would like to share it
with you maybe is there something that
you can learn from this some of you
might remember pretty much a year ago
when the CEO of Ferrari was standing
right here on the stage and he said one
thing that resonated with me he told us
that at Ferrari his people are so
passionate about what they're doing they
would even go to work if they didn't
didn't get a salary and to be quite
frank there's only one time in my life
when I can think of a moment where was
that passionate about what I was doing I
was standing on the screen and I was
taking a practice swing and I took
another practice swing and then I
approached the ball had a last look at
the hole and putted the ball and I
remember how the ball was aiming
slightly left at the hole but then it
took a break the break I had foreseen it
hit the back of the hole and disappeared
and I was ecstatic we made it we were
into Germany German tips and all my
friends came across we hugged each other
and celebrated each other we had made it
we became German champions before
enduring high school and college I
played on the German national golf team
and I remember I was really passionate
about what I was doing I really loved it
but at some point I realized I didn't
want to spend my life competing against
my best friends and also thought I have
a higher quarreling or let's call it
responsibility for society so instead of
turning pro I applied for college and
back then it wasn't such a hard decision
for me to go to college because luckily
I'd been accepted at one of Germany's
most exclusive colleges which I thought
was a great launch pad for a really
successful Korean little did I know how
long after making this decision I would
still struggle to fight my passion
little did you know how many sleepless
nights I would ask myself what do I want
to do with my life and as I said it even
when I got here it didn't really change
the first thing I was asking myself what
is it that I'm passionate about and I
didn't find a solution to that but then
I took this class across campus the car
it's called the lean launchpad well you
get the chance to work in your own
startup and it all started when I was
sitting on my couch at home with my
friend boishakh Bosch I guess cams
girlfriend and she's really passionate
about fashion
she taught me was truly inspiring story
how when she was born and raised in
Turkey she packed her bags and moved all
the way to New York where she studied at
the Fashion Institute of Technology one
of the best was in New York for fashion
and there she really loved what she was
doing she designed her own fashion
styles she presented them on a runway to
talent agents and buyers and she was
just passionate about what she was doing
but why should tell me how much she
loved fashion I could sense some
frustration in her face so I challenged
her in Austria by shock what happened
next and she tells me well today I work
in a cubicle in a nine-to-five computer
job for a mediocre fashion brand and I
don't really like what I'm doing and to
be quite frank I was really sad when I
heard that why because I know that she
had found her passion
let's caroms perfect so in a challenge
and aster explain me what is it exactly
that makes it so hard for you to become
your own boss to become a fashion
designer and she said well first of all
it's very expensive
I need a lot of money I need money
because I need to make up for this area
that I'm not earning and I need money
for the styles for the samples that I
need to create which costs up to $700 in
New York and I pushed back I said gosh
like what if we did the following what
if you created your designs in your free
time
and what if I took care of sourcing the
samples you from Asia where I'd been a
lot and only a fraction of the price is
what you have to pay to get yourself was
from over there and she got excited said
yeah this is this is really cool we
should do that but then she she thought
for a mom and said you know what it's
actually not only that I also need
somebody to take care of marketing
I need a showroom and I need somebody to
acquire customers for me and I thought
and I got excited about pushing back and
trying something that we've never tried
before you know be a little more
creative so I told her what if we
created this website where you can
upload your styles and I would drive a
lot of traffic on the website that could
give feedback on her styles provide
comments and maybe even pre-order them
and I could sense she got excited and
she said I really want to do that but
then she said you know what to be quite
frank the problem is a different one the
problem is I'm a fashion designer and
I'm not a business person I'm really
good at designing fashion items but I'm
not good at solving business problems
and I spent the last two months talking
to designers like boishakh and I got the
same answer over and over again I'm good
at designing fashion items I'm not good
at solving business problems there's one
thing that not all of you know I
actually started a fashion brand before
school and just to give you an example
this is one of the styles that my friend
Katie who was the designer and I are
selling right
in Germany I met KD a while ago and she
taught me about her passion to become a
designer to design purses clutches
wallets belts and shoes and all matching
in a color and I told her why don't we
send styles to India fly to India which
is what we did and visit the tailors who
sample for us we visited 12 of them one
of them provided really good quality so
we decided to buy the first batch 100
bags take them all to Germany put them
in the trunk of our car and we drove
around Germany we visited 300 boutiques
and I guess we've got around 60
customers today these 60 customers are
playing my friend celery right now and
allow me to be here what I want to say
is that we've got the skills to help
these people we have the skills to
enable them these people boishakh to
pursue their passion and I encourage you
to do the same thing too why because
helping barshak and helping my friend
katie has been the most rewarding
experience ever since I hold this plan
so when you leave the room why don't you
go across the street and talk to the
engineering students and ask them what
are you passionate about what are the
problems that you're trying to solve oh
why don't you talk to your med school
friend and ask him what are you
passionate about what are the problems
you're trying to solve maybe you can
help
sometimes even law school students have
good ideas why don't you talk to that
why don't you talk to that law school
friend of yours and ask them what are
you passionate about maybe you can help
them again enabling others to pursue
their passion is just as fulfilling as
finding your own passion and I want to
do this I want you to do the same thing
because I don't want you to wake up one
day after you leave the campus and find
yourself working in a cubicle for a
mediocre company in a job you're not
passionate about thank you